teens held captive and now we are
getting the first look at the conditions
police say they were subjected to it is
a story eight news now first told you
about it and now investigator Vanessa
Murphy
Center of this criminal case she has
more from the Regional Justice Center in
downtown Las Vegas
Addy Gonzalez appears to try to avoid
our camera as she leaves Court Monday
[Music]
She's accused of keeping her niece and
nephew who she had adopted locked up in
her North Las Vegas home these are
photos obtained by the 8 news now
investigators showing the bedroom where
the girl was found a bucket for the
bathroom a deadbolt on the outside of
the room the girl telling prosecutors
she was barely given any food or water
she and her brother saying they'd be
locked in the garage or bedroom for
extended periods of time during the
pandemic the girl as long as three to
four months the girl was seen trying to
escape from the second floor bedroom to
get water last November neighbors called
police
the girl got out and jumped over our
backyard seeking water when we saw her
she said she had climbed down using
sheets but she was heading back up
Gonzalez is also a longtime Clark County
School District employee a family
learning Advocate since 2005. she was
indicted by a grand jury on 27 charges
including child abuse and false
imprisonment the girl and her brother
testifying Gonzalez would beat them with
a belt a dog leash and a high heel shoe
her boyfriend Daniel omesqua and the
children's grandmother Maria positan
also indicted the trio appearing in
court briefly Monday as their lawyers
are prepared to argue they should not be
held in jail claiming they're not a
danger to the community and for example
all three of them go to church the
defendants are now out of custody
they're expected back in court next week
where custody issues and bail are
expected to be addressed reporting in
downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now Vanessa thank you Addie Gonzalez is
currently suspended from CCSD this is
unpaid leave per the negotiated
agreement with her bargaining unit
that's according to the district now her
niece set in court Gonzalez had been
working at Ruby Thomas Elementary School
all right so you're probably wondering
where are the brother and sister now
well the boy is now an adult said his
aunt had enlisted him into the army the
girl now also 18 but Child Protective
Services is still involved in her future